you built me remember that and you're
alive you have some awesome magical
powers Elsa but you didn't get to learn
how to use them until you were an adult
but what if you could have gone to a
magical school like Hogwarts as a kid
you would have been the most powerful
witch they had ever seen we got to
wondering which Hogwarts house you would
be in you've got great traits from all
of the houses I never knew it I was
capable of have you ever wondered which
Hogwarts houses the Disney Princesses
belong in keep watching to find out
where the Sorting Hat would put Elsa and
the rest of the princesses Moana Mahad
and Harry Potter have a lot in common
they are the chosen ones who were
destined to save their people and they
are both incredibly brave it's no
surprise that Moana would be sorted into
Gryffindor she is willing to take a huge
risk to save her Island she breaks her
father's rules and heads out on a grand
adventure
she used resourceful and doesn't always
think before she acts mallanna is one of
the bravest princesses there is Hickok
can't follow us into the water we make
it past the barrier islands we make it
to tip VT this is why she belongs in the
house of God Rick Gryffindor thou Bell
is definitely one of the smartest
princesses she always has her nose stuck
in a book
she loves to learn and in the
live-action version she invents a
laundry machine there is no doubt that
Bell belongs in Ravenclaw this is the
house that people who value intelligence
and learning are sorted into oh I
couldn't put it down
have you got anything new it's not that
there aren't smart people in other
houses just look at Hermione but Bhau
thinks learning and books are extremely
important well here I'll help you
the sorting hat would definitely put
fowl in the house of Luna Lovegood and
Cho Chang Merida
brave with fiery red hair we aren't
talking about one of the Weasleys we are
talking about Meredith she definitely
belongs in the same house as the Weasley
family though the Sorting Hat would put
Merida in Gryffindor without even
thinking about it after all her movie is
called brave Merida is a huge risk taker
she also stands up for what she believes
is right and when her mom turns into a
bear she doesn't hesitate to help her I
will not let you kill my mother
Rapunzel the last princess of Corona
spends 18 years learning how to
entertain herself she teaches herself
everything from how
paint and cook - ventriloquist catarrh
it takes a really intelligent person to
learn all of the things that she does
and she loves learning new things
Rapunzel belongs in ravenclaw she
reached the books she has over and over
and she's quick at adapting to life
outside the tower well I do like
duckling there's no question that
Rapunzel is super smart like the rest of
the Ravenclaw's Ariel Oh Ariel we think
the sorting hat would have a hard time
placing you in a Hogwarts house on the
one hand you love to learn about humans
and you are pretty daring when it comes
to spying on people you are kind when
you say Prince Eric but it takes a
cunning person to sell their soul to a
sea witch you are willing to do really
shady things to become human for that
reason we think you would do best in
Slytherin
so the wrens are willing to do anything
to achieve their personal goals if I
become human I'll never be with my
father or sisters again Tiana
the princess from New Orleans is an
amazing character she's smart and kind
but Tiana values hard work above
anything else she sings a whole song
called almost there
and she tells Prince Naveen the only way
to get what you want in this world is
through bawd work the house for people
who value hard work is hufflepuff
Tiana would do really well surrounded by
other friendly go-getters the Hufflepuff
house is also near the kitchens and she
loves to cook it's a perfect fit Mulan
let's get down to business and sort the
girl who saved China Mulan is definitely
a Gryffindor she disguised herself as a
man and joined the military for two
reasons first she didn't think it was
right for her disabled father to have to
fight you shouldn't have to go she knew
he wouldn't make it second she wanted to
save her country from the Huns she
didn't give up when the going got tough
Mulan shows us over and over what it
means to be brave you have saved us all
Pocahontas Pocahontas is another
princess that the Sorting Hat would have
trouble placing at first glance you
might see her as a Hufflepuff because
she is dedicated to peace
she's also brave like a Gryffindor and
smart like a ravenclaw but if you look
at her actions
Pocahontas belongs in Slytherin she was
a double agent she went against her
people by befriending one of the
colonists you could belong here but she
did that just to keep her people safe do
you know which other Slytherin was a
double agent
for a Snape onna there are a few
princesses that portray loyalties like
Anna she is extremely loyal to her
sister Elsa
even though else it causes a natural
disaster she doesn't give up on Elsa
even when Elsa gives up on herself
she's also loyal to Hans until she
realizes how evil he is and she's loyal
to her country of arendelle and will do
anything to save them this is why Anna
belongs in Hufflepuff they value loyalty
and hard work Elsa the queen of
arendelle has a lot of great traits but
she is definitely a strong leader she is
ambitious with her powers and she has a
high sense of self-preservation
Anna I belong here alone that's why she
runs away when her powers are revealed
these are all traits that belong to
slytherins we can't wait to see her
ambition and leadership skills come into
play in frozen to which princesses are
in your Hogwarts house let us know in
the comments thanks for watching give
this video a big thumbs up and don't
forget to subscribe to the things we'll
see you next time
[Music]